I was athletic I was a super job
Allstate in two separate sports but
there you go but I'm not a I'm not an
athlete is fast and can jump and give it
I what were you and I Allstate why let's
start well what were you uh sorry Mike
Mike psycho Catherwood here what will
you all stayed in what would the sports
soccer and baseball I played football to
you and I think I would have been better
at it if I started earlier whether
soccer yeah soccer you gotta have you
gotta have some foot speak as a
goalkeeper well now you gotta have real
reflexes that I did I do I was that I
great can die like we're nation and I
had good like like quick hands but well
your ally
well now let's go let's go to bed around
athletes in and I'm no you guys have to
you when you're around an athlete well
Brendan's math my brain is an athlete
yeah yeah well I want to get into this
cuz cuz I can see he's being
tight-lipped but hold on now now when
you play baseball Allstate you got good
hand-eye coordination yeah and you got
good torque you got you got a strong
ability to torque you got you got yeah
you got a good strong core and then Mike
were you a will you a catcher or an
outfielder I was their baseman third
pace didn't have to run but had quick
hands you know there you go so your
Allstate in California yeah that's
pretty good that's no joke second team
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
you're athletic
I'm athletic but I'm not an athlete well
no so now I'm saying I trained with that
like a you know I've seen with [ __ ]
athletes guys who are yeah job
unbelievably quick and it makes you
marvel you realize like we're not
playing on a level playing what's your
definition of an athlete be oh man that
it's come home right it's super
complicated because there's people who
are athletic but yeah I guess it just
depends like gamesmanship no none of
that [ __ ] I mean like there's like
if you've been around someone gets paid
to play right board that's a different
type of it like you I think you'd be
more tight-lipped about using the term
athlete yeah like if you've been in
those locker rooms and like even like I
don't I wouldn't consider myself a great
athlete because I've been around great
athletes you know no but dude
yeah I'm good athlete but if you've been
around some oh-oh-oh-oh 1% but in
comparison to the population you're in
the 1% I've had to I've had to pro pro
football players who played for a long
time yeah tell me who played with
Brennan tell me that the only reason you
didn't play in the NFL was because you
weren't seeing what by the right people
at the right time hmm that's pair your
your at your size your level of footwork
and your humidity inside it's truly
impressive I mean that just that's
uncomfortable for you to say because you
didn't do it yeah yeah and I was a like
people you could say like oh well you
were a good high school athlete yeah but
I also I was voided out of my mind well
you know I love that I know a lot of
like tricks to make it seem like I wrote
it out of your mind
yeah that's cool yeah you're such an
extremist yeah I mean you know I was
drinking every day and roided-out know
it's such a I never I never assumed that
like normal person life would happen for
me I really did and I never had any
vision of being a normal respectable
member of society working 9:00 to 5:00
you mean I just
you didn't any really I just like I
would did you wear a jean jacket and
drive a t-bird or something - no I did
drive like a pickup truck though like
you know headers and looking right you
did aftermarket exhaust the whole deal
yeah well you're yeah you're male now
you doing a little trt right now so no I
want you to look like it I'm gonna be 40
in a year and I think that's when I'm
gonna go talk to you special doctors in
Venice Beach you don't need to yeah but
I want to why you look he's I have
nothing else in my life dude your mic
back for days but what if he wants to
yeah that's in but his back goes on for
days I know guys who are doing they love
it yeah see I I would like to because I
have experience in abusing hormones and
so I don't want to go back to that world
but I would love to just feel better and
look better and yeah see about feeling
see I think people think when they got
air T there get all jacked and look like
now I can stone-cold or something like
that and it doesn't really work like
that
for a guy who's
had steroid abuse or you had renal
cleanse your testosterone was like
probably pretty low I don't assume after
that it was it's not like you probably
out the money do the right kind of
recovery and get your system back to
normal levels I tried I like Kim yeah
man I had a body both say that when you
do TRT testosterone it doesn't do the
work for you
no you won't be a bodybuilder so you
won't feel anything until you start
working out and you're yeah that's not
true that's not true that's not true to
you if your testosterone is low check it
out this way you have to do and getting
to be like the bodybuilder says that
yeah Rob bit instead you had just
injection and I look like this yeah yeah
I do yeah no I do
you're definitely shredded there's a lot
that goes into it however you're [ __ ]
running so much tests of your body it's
definitely growing while you sleep it's
why I knew a guy who will go unnamed he
was doing a thousand milligrams a day
passed and you guys CRT would be like
250 milligrams like every week maybe
every couple 1,000 he was in 2008 with
with growth and how is this heart no man
but you there's a fun game you could
play at Gold's Gym Venice Beach where
you go who's still alive and there's
these you know maybe 200 pictures on the
wall of these lectin why this
bodybuilder and by the way they're some
of them are like 40 and you're like well
that guy passed away at 28 that guy 33
you know Jesus really but people are
Universe terrorist people say there's no
proof that anyone's ever died from
steroids there's no proof that which
which is I mean it's not like fentanyl
or something where you take it and
you're dead correct but I mean who knows
a lot of guys have these fatal liver
problems and these heart conditions at
in their 30s now what could else could
you blame it for if it's an athlete I
would say the culprits more would be
painkillers yeah well the thing about
painkillers - is that almost everyone is
using is a what they call poly user
where you're not using just percocet
you're on percocet and xanax or and you
through you mix mix in those
benzodiazepines like the xanax and those
type of circuits training right that's
where you die
yeah and that's if you look at Robbie
Fletcher cocktail you look at every
famous kind of OD death in the last
couple years they're all using some type
of like anti-anxiety or one of these
it's a hose and those and then and why
is that the combination I guess I mean
this is way above my pay grade but from
sitting next to Drew for so long and
talking to him it's because it just is a
recipe for your body chemically it slows
your heart down to the point that you
don't yeah this is too much right self
ledger all those guys the other they're
doing that [ __ ] and then they go to
sleep yeah it's a coming if you're gonna
go not a bad way right well it's a nice
lock comfy I legitimately feel like such
a painful kind of empathy for people who
are addicted prescription pills because
I've been sober sixteen years and I got
to be honest it was very easy to come to
grips with the fact that I can't smoke
crack every day there was a there was no
lack for shirts it was very easy for me
to say I can't drink every day the human
beings are not designed to drink for
breakfast like there's one thing to have
a couple drinks after a long day at work
every guy deserves that sure yeah I was
drinking when I woke up to the point
when i black out and smoke grab a good
teeth for smoking crassness I my hair
line drew often says that my hairline
and my teeth are defy all that's what
I'm saying you're here should be [ __ ]
you're here shows like talents your
teachers look like Brian's bottom teeth
all of you I smoked up sand lots of
crack and shoe tobacco for a decade and
you have good genetics great genetic
goes to bear down I have great genetics
for longevity do drunk or Irish in
Mexican yeah those are two very good
choice yeah you know it for drugs
I had a great and not the I'm not saying
this is like a feather in my cap but I
had a tremendous appetite and ability to
do drugs and drink and I could get yeah
look at you now yeah right your feet out
you got your visiting wall this is kind
of a kind of a
- dude I guess his way what I would say
though is that I when it comes to the
prescription drugs like I really like
it's painful to me to think about
someone who is going to die or throw
their life away just something that a
doctor prescribed them that to me as an
addict I go wow that must be so hard to
wrap your head around you know because
like I said it wasn't difficult to look
in the mirror in 2001 in a hotel room by
myself
hitting the pipe going well this is
probably this is not a recipe for a high
quality life it's not gonna work out but
if you have a doctor prescribed
something - you think it's all good
you're a cop you got a back injury next
thing you know you're popping them every
day that's how I got thats how I got in
trouble my my my buddy was a doctor
right he goes I had no surgery and
reconstructs there Jeff tell the story I
wrote him before and we've talked about
it but and he goes ah bride got you so
he rested on prescription it's like 300
oxycontin yeah because you need it for
your nose but you only 300 oh my gosh I
was taken for my nose I was it kind of
feel good man then I got the the you
know everything out you know and I found
myself taking them keep taking them out
like at mom she can keep taking a little
more if they feel good I'm a problem
what do they feel like heaven
like an Angels like coming in your veins
so so I just would so I would just keep
I've just keep taking them and then I
realize like months later I just keep
popping these things and actually got a
refill those three hundred somebody I
was taking oh my god I kept taking them
and then I'd go out with my friends at
night downtown Denver but all instead of
it's right better for me to take one of
these and shove one beer and fight feel
buzzed and good then drink 12 beers mmm
yeah so I do that and I found myself
keep doing that keep doing my buddy
Klopp Klopp found it was a you're not
taking these iam and took it from me I
went cold turkey
good I was ghost [ __ ] I have a problem
mmm me okay I always pride myself on
discipline so I'm like one does it go
[ __ ] I got a problem I found it funny
very funny kept on you dove Davidoff
talks about that it's like falling in
love is that thing where you sit on a
couch and you and like you're at a party
and you realize that somebody spilled a
drink on it and it seeps through by the
time
get up it's too late you're like
[ __ ] faith you don't see it
happen yeah it just happens I I was who
I was were so I don't mean the Rhino go
I always think it would like when people
deal from OC's cotton - what's the
hardcore heroin heroin yeah God don't
get me around here and you know cuz
there's a part of me that goes I bet
that feels [ __ ] tremendous if you're
chemically set up for opiates you're
you're done you know so be my friends I
never once and I'm a massive drug addict
and I I just didn't take to heroin I
mean I would do it I'd read it was
better than being sober but I was not
someone who like I would I would inject
it and go this is it this is the rest of
my life now are you lence already
simulates I did it was like it was like
angels opening up their wings inside my
body I said well this yeah this is what
I need in life you know Artie Lange said
he did heroin yeah I think this is what
he said he said my head hit the pillow
and I went oh I'm in trouble cuz he knew
that that was that was it I had this
weird thing that I feel like you buy
everywhere around my friends my friends
ruther was an all-star wrestler great
wrestler really good-looking guy he did
heroin one time and he now is 50
something and he's living in a home for
homeless good he never he went to
Harvard or MIT I'd one of those and he
just never could never yeah I figure
myself doing that I have the rubber band
right thing and I think said Jimi
Hendrix ah there must be some kind of
way out of here yeah you're famous whoa
arms yeah yeah I've always wanted to be
so many like Iggy Pop yeah overdoses
with opiates now are such an epidemic
it's because they're they're blending
[ __ ] two kids are dying no I totally
understand why people are wary of guns
and they have guns are murder machines I
get it I'm a black and water pro-gun guy
but at the same time I totally
understand why people freaked out a real
guns but what I don't understand is this
America right now has this obsession
with gun violence and if you look at the
numbers it's really not something we
need to worry about in comparison to
opiates to opioids which every one of us
every single person of a millions of
people that are gonna listen to this
podcast and
every single one of you is directly
affected by hope you to be correct
whether it be your mom or your
girlfriend or you yourself or whoever it
is isn't it yeah yeah it was really that
bad I'm sure dr. drew deals with all the
time and I want to talk about this
because everyone knows I'm balls deep in
teen mom and I miss an episode right how
many seasons I know weird I don't know I
can just log myself out where the [ __ ]
am i hoping that I watched are you
hoping they'll get out of it what is it
tonight it's a complete [ __ ] show it's
the only reality show that I watch
besides maybe cops yeah regular watch it
too I do I mean I'm not like Brendan I
don't I'm not bald you know that sure
you're not if I see it if I'm if I have
some free time on my hands to watch TV
that isn't Teletubbies or some [ __ ] you
know with my daughter each I will I will
you know scour the channel since I can't
watch murder porn anymore cuz my wife's
a hippie and she totally won't let me
what have you seen the fara porno murder
porn is like the discovery ID or the the
Dateline you know the it's these
documentary style shows that are about
you know murdered and I love those by my
wife like 40ml that's it love it love it
I love it too but my wife said I can't
watch it why because she said brings
negative energy into the house and slap
her face I know kidding but slight shake
shake that [ __ ] but I you know
occasionally watch the Teen Mom and I
honestly think that it's one of the most
real reality shows because they show
these kids poor lives getting [ __ ] up
by prefer having to deal with reality
smacking them in the face and if they
candy coated Teen Mom I don't think it
would be a special of a show the fact
that they showed these it's wrong and
you know dealing with having their own
children it's Teen Mom I the team
practicing went down some crazy number
when that show dude yeah like 40 percent
or something what because it's at I'm
good in the world well especially when
it kit way at the time when it was
released is a big deal shows how it
doesn't work out well so you know some
are doing alright but then you just see
that it's just it's a having a kid like
I can I talked about before we came in
like and you know
to be like how many kid you'd be in the
most solid relationship having a kid it
will test everything you're worth man it
is a [ __ ] you know I'm financially
you know I'm stable
I'm mid-30s it's all good man and
relationships good but it's [ __ ] I
don't care who you are you know imagine
means 16 I can nothing and imagine
imagine if you had a baby with the
six-year-old girl you were dating
imagine that [ __ ] knuckleheads the
mother of your childhood do you I'm
saying that anal at 16 so you know yeah
man I mean I I different person you are
literally about verse I'm a different
person I was three years yeah so when I
watched that show it's just like you
know this one girl you know she she was
16 and her man decided to give up the
baby for adoption so now 10 years later
they they still want to visit the baby
stuff like that they've had their own
kid and then she they're like yes we're
pregnant again then she has a
miscarriage oh then she's suicidal let's
check into rehab she's suicidal so you
go through all that and this other dude
now he has opiate prompt and you see it
on TV him going in and out and then
they're gone and then his girl goes oh
[ __ ] we have checked him into rehab now
he gets taken away from his son it's
just this it's so real it's real turn
almost real thing on TV besides
intervention but it's [ __ ] intense
intervention but even intervention
there's there's a Hollywood aspect to it
and it's not the interventionist fault
it's the addicts fall correctly
my question is you give people an addict
an active drug addict on TV believe me
they can show up yeah my question is
this is a symptom of something what is
it a symptom of what's coming said why I
like it no no the opiate addiction drugs
this is a symptom of what is it
spiritual ennui what's going on I think
Americans there's this funny thing that
goes on that we acknowledge that there
are cultural rituals and cultural kind
of mores with every other culture in the
world we all French people like their
wine and telling people like to talk
with their hands we all kind of
acknowledge that they're these things
that exist that are
gorgeous anchors we don't examine that
Americans are just [ __ ] crazy and
they're all wrong people are like
looking for these answers like why do we
have so many guns why do we buy giant
cars why do why do we all use 90% of the
world's drugs in this country and I
think it's just there's a there's an
outlaw mentality this kind of Maverick
ethic that is just comes with being
American but it's also melting pot like
you take in all this no but we bought
isn't is it is it though do you think it
could also be the fact that people for
whatever reason and maybe it's young
people whoever it is are not oriented to
purpose meaning where to place their
energy no I think they've always been
that way I think they have but it's
worse now today I really mean purpose
when you when you have Instagram because
it's hard you make money off that's
criminal
so you're saying money off youtube that
my daddy oh yeah when your dad goes come
on son quit playing the [ __ ] video
games that's not a good career Oman
right is a career now but you would say
what percentage of kids that play video
but it's still a possibility it's a
possibility in that and then possibly
does mean one play in the NFL does seven
I just think that with the the media the
ubiquity of media and and the way that
it's kind of force-fed to us
man it's hard especially kids nowadays
they live their lives in public you know
I so much of what I dealt with as a
fifteen-year-old like my problems I
thought that I was the only guy in the
world that had this problem and I dealt
with it
the only I really could this guy Brian I
does not help you describe this guy
Brian that's what I mean like doesn't
that help the younger kids now because
not really let's say let's say I'm a
transgender I'm a gay kid growing up
right now I've been out I can reach out
to someone else who has that other than
that I'm in this small village you have
a community small city in Aurora where
I'm like dude I'm the only kid who
thinks like this what the [ __ ] law by
myself I'm gonna commit suicide I think
I think like everything else is a
double-edged sword so one of the
problems that I think is that yes you
can find community online you can find a
cyber community and I think that's worth
something but the other problem is that
there are a couple things one we've
talked about where you can [ __ ] up one
time and that lives forever yeah yeah
but but that that will follow you around
forever but but
also something else that's talking this
guy Brian Edward Hill is a [ __ ] smart
guy he um he's a comic book he's a he
creates comic books he writes for that
TV show Titan and he said something
really interesting he said nowadays you
can say something and back in the day
somebody who had a rebuttal to you had a
problem with that had to it was there
was a long-form rebuttal
there was a there was a debate on TV or
there was a law a letter written now you
can tweet an impulse and that tweet gets
retweeted and kids are doing this so
that all of a sudden you get bombarded
with this impulsive none thought-out
neurotic sort of emotional response but
yeah and emotional ammunition as opposed
to kind of like are too thoughtful
articulate back and forth right and any
damaging to it all so I think it it you
also again it's double-edged sword
because I think it's great that people
can see into the lives of their heroes
or their favorite athlete or seen the
good you know if killed Tim Tebow's
Instagram see the good he's doing he's
very cute Tim Tebow there's very few but
then also the issue is if I'm a six year
old girl and I'm a Kylie Jenner fan and
I'm 16 and my parents bought me a
Volkswagen brand invokes like an awesome
car but I see kylie jenner 16 she is a
[ __ ] G Wagen and then you start that
and then how about this and then they
create all oh and I don't have those
lips and I don't have that and they
created a cyber avatar again my buddy
Brian was talking mothers they create a
cyber avatar of their of their life so
though that post on Instagram and I'll
show you doing all these things that
aren't even real but they're creating an
avatar so they're they're not only
they're mimicking somebody like Kylie
Jenner they are creating it's not even
real there there's an avatar of what kid
boy or girl
is happy with themselves as a teenager
no one's no one's comfortable or happy
with who they are everyone's insecure
and and rightfully so I mean you're you
don't really understand the world you
don't have a lot going for you you don't
have but usually you have a job or car
or anything to speak of you know what
I'm saying you just feel like it's you
against the world and every kid really
has that feeling of
that that detachment from that I have
the happy place in society now you have
the ability to create a completely false
reality to compensate for that as
opposed to being forced to be
introspective and dive into it which is
which is what you were forced to do even
just 15 years ago you know and I like
the bullying's a prompt to so like if
I'm insecure about something right and
most speak the trolls at school there's
trolls even when you guys were coming up
and I was come at her but they don't
have a voice now the trust yeah they
like me I didn't [ __ ] them here just
a same thing yeah we did like alright
we're gonna fight yeah you got beat up
now yeah usually got beat up or you just
gonna throw this cheeto fingers I was a
great role and then I became a non
highschool troll cuz I got the [ __ ]
kicked a correct you're like oh I don't
want to be that guy yeah I'm getting no
girls I have zero girlfriends cuz I'm a
[ __ ] hater I look like [ __ ] I need to
figure my life out I just got beat up
for being a troll but nowadays the
trolls no one really you know I'm not
gonna can't seek you out there's nothing
can really do so you can live that troll
lifestyle you're gonna you know
negativity gathers up so they're like oh
I'm my life sucks let's get together and
so they look at people doing well
maybe it's in entertainment sports and
then they put their negative vibes on
them but they're never held accountable
mmm right issue so kids have to deal
with that all the time now yeah where
before oh yeah if you didn't like me
cool or if you thought I sucked that
lacrosse or football whatever I was
doing cool man
yeah have you noticed that the new news
picks up on random tweets so somebody
say something gonna go the Twitter
backlash has been terrible and then they
post a bunch of negative [ __ ] from Joe
Schmo and there's a million good ones
too you're like dude why you turn this
in the news it is a double-edged sword
though I do think and I don't have any
like research to base this on but I just
think from kind of every once in a while
poking my head into teenage circles I
think a 17 year old 16 year old kid
today's way more sympathetic to people
who have it rough way more true there
was a you know I live in Venice which is
one of the most legendary homeless
problems in the
country and I see kids nowadays high
school kids riding their skateboard down
the boardwalk and they'll they'll throw
a couple bucks to a homeless guy and
they'd sit and talk with homie yeah do
you know I hate to admit it I think back
to my ears me my buddies would be way
more prone yeah
do you know United Nations actually
clocks things like inequality and and
and actually thoughts about how they do
these really interesting service about
whether or not prejudice and racism and
bigotry are going down or other and by
most almost all accounts of and I'll
explain why they know this racism among
young people and bigotry among young
people all over the world is going down
worker and why they know this because
they'll take like yeah guys do the the
the some like a lot of racism start
right from your grandmother or whatever
old school right like my grandma's from
England some of the stuff she would say
like Jesus Christ my mom's like that's
why she was raised didn't know any
different she doesn't have any education
but now all kids are coming up like most
your heroes are they're not they don't
look like you there might be white black
Mexican ya know but whatever surely your
hero your senior just white and you're
seen them and you see them that they're
good people they're they're just like
you and check out how they know that so
they'll look at really interesting
things they'll look at how many times
the N word has been googled for jokes so
yeah so so there's a way to look at
there's a way to look at a massive
database and say how many times how many
how many times have n-word jokes been
googled and then they'll say well what
kind of people do that how would we know
they'll also find that people that
Google the n-word and reasons to use it
are ways to use it there are also people
who Google Social Security or things
about retirement so they're older older
yeah yeah and young people are not doing
that and it's fascinating but that's a
worldwide trend so it's becoming you're
like you said because of social media
because of the web more it's we're it's
easier to kind of see what it's like to
be somebody else well and you just see
more people and movies lifestyles more
I mean and movies if you I'll never
forget this call because I grew up in a
in a neighborhood where if you were
white anglo-saxon you were by far the
minority you know I grew up in a really
diverse neighborhood and so to me this
was it was fantasy it was so surreal to
hear this call on Loveline this kid
called from rural Ohio lived just
outside of Cleveland calls up he says uh
I had a girlfriend for a while and I
really liked her but she's going back to
her country of origin she's Chinese what
do I do
and I go uh what do you mean what do you
got find a new girlfriend I guess he's
like no no no I really I've discovered I
have a real thing for Asian girls what
do I do I go [ __ ] find an Asian girl
what do you yeah what is El fort where
where do I where do I do that he was no
hiyo and he literally didn't know where
he would see another wife and I go dude
save up some money get a Southwest
flight out of LAX go about ten miles
east of Monterey Park yes head will blow
off your [ __ ] nap yeah it'll be like
it'll be like Disneyland we got balls
but it made me think like okay there's a
real different America and by the way
with this country we live in it's really
like 50 different countries you know
there's a Holden lifestyle and some
people are just not as exposed to things
and it becomes normalized to people who
are lucky enough to have it normalized
but like I was thinking about the other
day I have I grew up with gay family
friends and to me it was never like it
would it was never like a big deal
the these guys this guy one guy his name
is Tom and his boyfriend weirdly enough
was named Jerry and dad and my mom and
dad just said like you know how mom and
dad are sweethearts that's that's what
Tom and Jerry are and I was you know at
five years okay know the law you know so
it's like it's like exotic food if
you're exposed to exotic since you're a
little kid it's not exotic if you're
exposed to yeah
all different races and gay people and
whatever it may be it's not well that's
why that's why we're Syria without
getting upset because I grew up around
Arabs rate and I know exactly what
Syrians I know the good people that
they're also really modern they're also
not these these idea they're religious
fanatics oh no they're not
yeah the average Syrian is exactly like
that must be it's it's it's I can't read
about it because I know what's up 180
here I [ __ ] miss Loveline man how did
you I thought was one of my favorite
shows I said a lot I love war I love dr.
drew you and dr. so good to get me just
doing show now but yeah Loveline was so
good boy
so it helps I mean we're like legit I
mean much like you to get he it's not
like which happened so often in radio
and God friends man is a show if we
weren't buddies I think both would quit
by this yeah there's a legendary
collection of radio teams who they
[ __ ] despise and then but they get on
the air and they could just hang out you
know we couldn't do this I could have
faked that I don't like Jews my boy I
text him every day I take the anyway
he's the best can you tell him that last
night on the Teen Mom reunion his orange
sweater underneath that sports coat was
[ __ ] terrible he ruined my expense he
deserves to be clown for his fab you
can't Brennan cannot he will not stand
for a lack of fashion right my record
I'm like here we go baby open and the
reunions of my favorite to so much drama
I wanted to update on everyone and on
here we go and the Suzy hits the screen
yo goddamnit drew it's like a mock it's
weird and he deserves
you know you deserves your hatred will
you tell them for me yeah
stana shape though address Walt
legitimately swole yes strong it's our
new podcasts the swirl patrol she's
would patrol yes that right yeah that's
the topics on there o comprehensive
fitness meaning obviously like staying
in shape but then mental health o
everybody yeah and so what's he think of
trt he's a doctor he really wants to do
it himself because Drew's a hundred and
four years old but he had that prostate
prostate so he sees a little sketched
out about it but he he thinks look for
people who are truly deficient in
hormones it's it's awesome it makes it
just like anything makes sense if you're
let's take this why we but we might a
[ __ ] consulate Ayman so we put
testosterone on such this pedal stool
you know it's like well it's steroids no
it's not yeah bringing you produce that
now if you're injecting two thousand
milligrams and doing some crazy [ __ ]
within you I feel like you're setting
yourself up for I feel like you're my
buddy shoot but I feel like you're
revving up and getting ready yourself
he's looking young yeah I don't I mean
IIIi was diagnosed with low testosterone
in college they thought at first I was
diabetes and then I got low testosterone
training yeah I've been waiting rooms on
fourth grade that can't be held yeah
running sprints at 5:00 in the morning
yeah give him the head not stuck but my
dad's tackle football at 106 we put in
all these artificial things into our
body and you know testosterone is one of
the most beneficial things that
naturally exists inside us and to do a
little tweak here to get yourself up to
a healthy level I don't understand how
anyone has a problem with it cuz it's on
a pedestal because when we hear we when
we hear testosterone we think there are
steroids mark over our a rod lance
armstrong's like no Jesus Christ it's
just like anything but back to dr. drew
yes he was on uh I think what's the
Hollywood mediums a terrible
freeze-frame was he yes I got to make
fun of him for that I thought Hollywood
meet him no you know why was crying on
there you know why his wife I love Susan
Penske I really do she's my girl I like
we text back and forth all the time
mostly black penis but thank you uh he
she is all about psychics and palm
readers in that whole world do I dislike
the show with you I work free right and
so I met with the the head of e I'm in
there and we're going through things
aren't good and I said listen this might
cause me not to get the gig I just got
understand something here is that Tyler
kid the medium the psychic is that real
and she was Brennan I've I've been here
for maybe two months I was in person if
it's fake I don't know how the hell he's
doing it I've never seen anything he has
a talent to read people or anything
stuff out I have no idea husband I do
not think he doesn't drive the day he
doesn't I know do it I think he's an
elite Allenton at being able to read
people or
here's the problem though it idles
baloney I don't believe they're faking
it but what I do think is that we're
getting an edit you work in television
guys you know what we're getting is an
edited product we don't think he goes to
a TV 40 times he goes and someone with
an M I'm getting someone with an M and
he's a phony but also I'm and that's why
but here's the thing
he so they said hope they'll be out of
reading and they don't know who's gonna
come this way they tell me
he'll be out Orion they don't know who's
gonna come so sometimes he'll be talking
to the celebrity and he'll go with this
name this name this name and to find out
its people from someone on the camera
crew the boom like and it'll have a show
yeah but you know what they do so in the
guy crossing over that that phony that
they would have a microphone in the
waiting room and they could hear people
talking and 60 minutes did a whole thing
on would you mean oh I'm crossing over
that that phony that bad guy who talks
to the dead and gets people crying they
had a microphone it said they wouldn't
he'd have a show you'd be waiting in a
waiting room their microphones they're
listening in or you're talking about
okay David playing who's that does this
stuff and can read things in addition
and stuff like David can make you think
David can make you think that you are
that he was magic dude he can read [ __ ]
he can give you a name of like what the
fourteen-year-old love of your life huh
it's well and he explained it to me I'm
not gonna say how but he explains to me
oh [ __ ] blame you no no I don't hold a
[ __ ] I go yes that makes sense we think
he's just good at reading people I do
certain things there's always know about
people
right there's certain bands I think also
some people they said they even said it
these are people that are coming to him
whether they're random strangers or not
he doesn't have a chance to prepare
there's skilled people that are very
openly receptive to this type of
information you know so they like you
after drew dr. drew was like dude look
at watch it doctor like this is dr. drew
I was like now he was close he was close
then can i watch ladies they talk about
his dad I think so I forget then how
about this how about this no
you know robin thicke the gentleman that
I've designed us right Robert he did
Robin Thicke went to his house champion
cocksman yeah Robin Thicke was first
team our champion my wife is all about
his son is two minute came on oh yeah
well that he's a beat he's a bigot are
you the big athletic guy played
full-contact hockey and full time yeah
beautiful tan yeah he was a team Gracie
yeah I'm like beautiful TV show his
son's killer movie was so check this out
back-to-back the title of the medium
yeah so the Hollywood medium so he went
to Robin Thicke Alec Alan Thicke sorry
the dad I'll take like a month before he
passed away
oh and you listen as he goes because
there's something wrong with your heart
yes you need to get it checked out in
Allen's like Wyatt eels I'm telling you
I have a heart condition you need to get
it looked at he goes I will get right on
that
doesn't look at it month or two later
dies of a heart attack
how they faked that tell me that I don't
know well it's coincidence no but there
is a chance that they could have
researched him and if he has a family
history of congenital heart disease or
you know I'm saying like what's - he's a
he's a famous celebrity he's been famous
for 40 years it's easily I'm not I don't
believe it mine I have to talk about
health it's gonna help with family
dimepiece but I mean your family's white
really good to just take into
consideration that blood pressure is
going to be something that we really
have to keep in mind
now heart issues that happen amendments
not in common but the thing is is that
see right like this I know where to
start okay when it comes to like a
family and a gene perspective it's
possible that within your family there
might be multiple men who end up at a
later age dealing with blood pressure
issues but also deal with either a heart
murmur or heart arrhythmia but I feel
like I have to kind of go to heart and
this kind of correlates with blood
pressure so just kind of keep that in
mind I have a couple people who you know
kind of came here and acknowledged
passing in a bit of a similar sense and
it's almost saying like keep in mind
your own heart because there's a man who
was very stubborn who passed away and he
acknowledges dying as a result of this
heart problem let's talk about message
don't be stubborn like I was and the
feeling is like this is a strong guy
he's great he's lovely but he was really
frustrated at the fact that he neglected
this because this is something that
could have been treatable exactly how he
died Vegas no there's just a feeling of
what I've done again if he had a history
of heart problems crying oh they
acknowledged it in the beginning though
that he knows that he has it like a
family history I mean you know that's
all it's a good guess but he's right you
know
yes I have a very pretty freaky funny
it's an older man you know little guys
month attorney goes do you need to check
on your heart and he died thing just
coincidence I do that kid yeah this
kid's good though yeah he's great he's
an incredibly talented personality he's
not have you seen Long Island medium
hold on Long Island medium will sellout
huge yeah and in a live crowd we'll do
the readings yeah my friend random
people I even I'm telling you if you
have a receptive if you have a receptive
audience it's much different my wife and
I did a podcast with you know again
Susan Pinsky used to do this podcast
based on psychics and stuff and we both
went in together and my wife's in there
just lapping it up and of course she's
crying oh my god I can't believe and I
go in there you know fully skeptical and
she's like you know I'm getting someone
talking to me from heaven and
warning me about addiction and things I
go what the fight you work with dr.
Drew's wife we'd like obviously like you
know you know and I'm saying so I
there's no I was not receptive Brett
Gurewitz from Bad Religion he also owns
even founded epitaph records he has a
tremendous story that kind of shed some
light on this whole world really he was
at the height of his addiction in the
mid 90s and just a really really bad
drug addict but he had also you know he
founded epitaph records and at the time
offspring second album smash had just
came out and it was sold like 30 million
records no doubt
came out with the albums that put him
over the top so he's he's making money
hand over fist I mean he literally was a
multi multi-millionaire in a matter of
months and but he was having this his
serious trouble with addiction so he
goes to at the recommendation of a bunch
of people that are like there's this
medium the Sega that can help guide you
and get you out of you know she goes he
sits down with the person the lady takes
one look at a guy who's frail and thin
covered in tattoos wearing a t-shirt and
beat-up jeans and she goes I know that
you're having money issues and it's
gonna pass but you're gonna have to
buckle down and really take a good look
in the mirror because your financial
issues are not going to end on their own
he's like you're you're so right you
know forty million dollars what was her
name terrible woman
Brown was her last name was her Sylvia
Browns of a bridge horrifying he was she
the one who was like I need some flying
rod
convicted syslog convicted for fraud and
she this so funny how he says she goes
on I see your husband he died in water
and I see a lot of water and a woman
goes he was burned yeah she goes he died
in 9/11 he was burned in the towers she
goes then she goes maybe well I see
water maybe it was the sprinklers I
don't know oh hell no he's an awful hell
no well like that Tyler Hollywood medium
when he did the Kardashians I'm like oh
here comes oj citizenship because you
know remember kris Jenner's best friends
with Nicole Brown right like here we go
baby let's do and Robert well Robert
worked on the on the defense team you
know be sick if he's like your father's
telling me Oh Jay did it
your father's tell me I'm kidding to it
here's what you need to be the biggest
rating is the whole time well time it
we're talking - this is hellacious a lot
of people with uh with dr. drew yeah I
was like why is he dressed like in 1990s
doctor man I think he could he has more
fashion offer than he does now mister on
TV first off he's jacked any where's the
the black t-shirt and the jeans not -
Wayne no like yeah off the air but then
I really feel like his speculation but
he prides himself on in a world of like
people who put doctor in front of their
name and then give advice dr. drew is a
a practicing physician he still sees in
Pasadena he still sees patients yeah
every week you know he's still in there
you know doing it and also really really
really devoted to addiction medicine
which is now gonna become probably the
biggest one of the biggest aspects of
medicine in the future because of all
the addiction but either way he really
prides himself on the fact that he
became a TV personality kind of by
happenstance it was his break love line
love like the TV show oh that's right
when you roll up that's [ __ ] right did
it back then you got understand 23 years
ago Dan Loveline started as a once a
week show on k-rock because every radio
station under FCC law has to have at
least an hour of community service radio
it's mandatory all if you're on the FM
band I don't know about the am band as
well I believe
hey look if you're an FCC regulated
radio station you have to have do
community service Lovell I started as a
they got this crazy wacky DJ and they
hired a medical student at USC who
happened to be in Pasadena where k-rock
was at the time it was Drew and they'd
come in and they'd answer questions
about drugs and what a brain it's crazy
and then next thing you know it became
this thing and then when Carolla came on
obviously it shot into the roof so now
dr. Drew's on TV every day people love
the show he's on the radio every day and
he just kind of accidentally becomes
this television guy bad his core he
is a dog his top priorities being a
doctor and people because of his now
massive fame with celebrity rehab and
all this stuff people can get it twisted
and I think he does makes a concerted
effort to kind of always reestablish I'm
doctor so that's why I dress it's like
like [ __ ] 1992 pediatrician well
because guys like dr. Phil give and I
love dr. Phil however dr. Phil gives
guys like dr. Drew a bad name
he's dr. Phil isn't a doctor asset but
then he talks you know but he doesn't he
doesn't really give like medical now you
know he was really really wealthy way
before Oprah yeah you know that Oprah he
was a guy who you would hire who could
teach you how to talk to juries oh yeah
so yeah so he's a really brilliant guy
no I know he's smart another one when
Oprah said come to Chicago he goes now
you come to me in Atlanta I'm not going
to Chicago overcame and because she got
sued by the beef cattle the cattle
industry for going bad on beef and cuz
beef went fell in price you know when
when there was and so he taught her how
to speak to juries he punked me and then
and then the next thing you know he
basically and then she would bring him
on the show and then Mike and I were
talking about this - how the [ __ ] did
Oprah get so because she recommends a
book she's some Starbucks for anything
was one she's also [ __ ] I went on
when you say amazing why be okay so as
an actress she's a killer like you don't
give a [ __ ]
she got big which she got two acting
roles because she was Oprah yeah but she
killed it she know she killed a lot of
people get actually say Oprah is
inspiring because she's in that know
like so here tell me why your give me an
exactly oh there's another one number
one color purple I mean she she when you
watch her as an actress she I think she
studied as an actress I believe that she
was she want to get into show business
but she's a phenomenal actress but like
Quincy Jones saw her and Quincy Jones
was the one who said this girl has got
something yeah you know but what really
makes hope her amazing was that she had
this newfound sort of success she had an
ability to communicate and so people
just
oh and she was they she cut across all
lines black women white women everybody
she was the person that people and
apparently then she said I'm I need to
take this new this this this popularity
is a very serious obligation hurtful
yeah so I'm not just going to be a talk
show host who talks about sensationalist
[ __ ] which she was doing at the time
yes she goes I want a boy I want a book
club she was I want people reading I
want to showcase authors I want I want
to do it and she knew that when she
endorsed something the [ __ ] blew up like
so he came be Watchers she all that
shitload of the oh but so it became the
Oprah that's had a weight problem though
right something yeah yeah again I think
it's relatability my green yo-yo died
all the time um Katie Couric told an
amazing story about how Deborah Norville
when she was on that today showed that
it was a very short-lived experience for
her and the reality was that she was too
pretty that women would wake up in the
morning and they didn't want to listen
to her it makes sense and and she was
too pretty of course things are an easy
right and so with Oprah I think they're
in a look in 1988 or whatever when her
syndicated show started when she
transferred over into being like this
mega celebrity it was unheard of that
someone would expose the vulnerabilities
and the dark side of their life there's
we lived in a world of really kind of
shiny celebrities that didn't have to
deal with TMZ and stuff especially on
daytime TV right and she was like no I
deal with weight issues I was molested
for a long time as a kid yeah I grew up
in in the ghetto I had a terrible really
a weird relationship my mom I didn't
establish relationship my dad till my
teeth she's just she just threw it out
there and people her and on top of that
she's on the fence why don't we
articulate and talented you know hoped
you know very talented like when she
talks it's like he's special she's
highly intelligent oh by the way can act
with the best of them and did you see
her speech I think was that the Golden
Globes I think which everyone I worked I
remember there's so much pressure on I'm
like and even in the pretty sure like I
don't think she mail deliver like
there's so much expectations there was
like
what she can do and she just [ __ ] guy
goes home run out of the park like oh my
god she's so powerful man but that
daytime TV like now obviously she's off
so I guess it's Ellen she's Rachael Ray
for a little bit filled in right rich
raping dr. Phil's on there I wish how
long would keep doing stand-up Ellen was
one of the great Stanley well that's
what Brandon and I were talking about
before the show is like the Ellen may
not be the the most relatable to
everyone in the daytime audience but she
has such like people don't I guess if
you're too young or you just not that
into it as a kind of like a comedy geek
you realize she has immense comedy crap
she's not just someone who was my Bob
Saget or you with Bob Saget or Bob tell
you it's a legend then but also Bob
Saget and then even Howie Mandel people
forget man or like if you're a kid you
know Eddie Murphy as the talking donkey
direct or Nutty Professor oh dude I went
to the Laker game with my my niece who's
she's 20 now but this was show time like
not show time but this was Shaq and Kobe
Domino so this 2004 okay and I go to the
Laker game with my niece and she's
sitting next to me and Robert De Niro
walks up and is four rows in front of us
and I'm like who [ __ ] Bobby D Bobby
and she goes my Uncle Mike it's Meet the
Fockers it's Meet the Fockers I'm like
oh my god Travis Bickle yeah is but
think about now if you're kidding now
you do Robert Daryl I got that like see
gotta make those hockey movies yes right
like he's hustling movies now for he's
making some terrible choices movie you
know the horrible word with being to pay
the bills do you ever see that and it
sucks what happens here is that that
african-american girl or whatever and
he's he's like the earlier you see and
they like argue in a restaurant he's
like you know reason I do these [ __ ]
movies cuz to pay these bills
[Laughter]
yeah no that's real yeah what yeah you
got caught on this girl you want the
reason have to make these [ __ ] movies
now to pay the bill something like that
zach galifianakis it's true that
confidence is heaven's house built in
here in town and he and when they'd have
to they're like we have to put another
wall up here there's got to be a
retaining wall it's gonna cost another
30 grand or hunter granary anko um you
know now I got to do another shitty
movie to afford this storm off and the
road workers starting this serious is
you guys you can't like measure how
[ __ ] amazing Bobby DS Oh watching
Goodfellas the other night and you're
saying oh yeah casino but I would you
speaking of people who Punk me Ray
Liotta Punk me too really yeah how so
would it mean we I was at a UTA party
which is like a 8 big agency here in LA
my wife is represented by them or was I
believe and we it was a Oscars UTA party
and I'm like [ __ ] I'm in Black Tie get
to go and hubbed up with the best you
know the biggest thing let's do this so
we go to this party and I feel wildly
insecure about being there because hey
I'm I'm some chicks white husband I'm
not even an actor or Lita and we're
there and Ray Liotta from across the
room makes a beeline for us I mean like
he's staring at my wife and I within 10
yeah walking towards us and he goes
right in my wife's face do you you uh
you're that girl you're that girl from
the show the show and she goes rules of
engagement he's like yeah you're
fantastic I love that show I love you
and she goes oh thank you so much you
know means a lot coming from he said
yeah yeah and this is your husband the
soccer player eyes you thought you were
[ __ ] uh and I don't know no he
thought I was my wife's ex-husband
Landon Donovan oh [ __ ] and Donovan no
I'm the new husband yes Oh Oh what do
you do I go I'm in radio he goes
Nandanam has got nothing on you bro
oh no he's fertilize them no I disagree
he's not good-looking dude any well I
listen I may be a hell of a more of a
dime piece but he's a great sloppy eater
marginally considered the greatest
American soccer player ever and I'm not
the greatest anything ever and he made a
phenom sucker lots of money
demson I don't did he play in Europe he
did he came back but the Galaxy signed
him after that and he paid well paid him
he's a stud I'm sure but it looks to
Portland you [ __ ] me
well that's a weird thing though I know
I hate to admit Halsey I got shorter
than me and my base take a 7 it's good
smuggling 5/8 oh my god I'm such a dick
home he's always been cool to me though
I mean I you know he's never never been
like any yes salaries only formula where
we said yeah listen
that the only four million a year to me
is [ __ ] knob [ __ ] yeah and that
doesn't include endorsements and bro no
me we're talking about Linda now you
don't tired start talking about that
stuff from what I hear thick Foster scan
yeah and my wrists are hot now you know
there's a there was a way I love to say
that I was in that guy but when my wife
and I first started dating and like it
became serious I definitely thought to
myself like oh my god hey I don't make
as much money as her by a long shot
she's gonna sitcom kind of cool the
seven seasons or eight seasons and then
and then when that Sid commented she
went on to another network sitcom with
Julia I'll be honest we dude if you
dated my wife I would be very happy
because you're a man you're a good guy
and you you like like when you think
about divorcing and which I do all the
time just kidding divorced and then your
your children would have to be raised by
another man you're the guy I would
choose oh so yeah I feel nothing good
call right there very nice
but you are you're a great guy you're
smart you're manly I would love to just
how you for like 10 15 years well I'm
doing my thing just feel right into the
big brown I shouldn't we have the
schedule to do it now if you want you
can go and the podcast L out show very
very free I see you all over though then
yeah now yeah
are you working over at Kevin and bean
because when I don't know I was
temporarily but I I now fun with their
with that standard I do Ellis once a
week that's my honestly that's my you
Ellis on what like Fridays used to Ellis
on fret do you like doing that love it
yeah absolutely love it yeah hilarious
right up your alley I like Jason suit
yeah love Jason Jason Jason is a very
very solid dude there's no I don't worry
sometimes that especially big fans of
his the the cartoonish kind of nature of
his presence will outshine if he's like
really good guys smart I see at all time
yeah he's just a solid dude it's always
cute always the past you know yeah tall
he's great as well the other but it's
just salt crew there anyway but for like
we're winning I would do like when you
stop well you but you've always been
doing radio like it's not like when love
lines start stop you you know you just
went away no I waited started doing am
talk political radio and which was like
really exciting to me I was like oh my
gosh I'm gonna play at the big-boy table
for once people are not gonna look at me
is like Oh funny morning radio guy were
like wacky nighttime guy who talks about
sex they're gonna look at me as like a
broadcaster and it and it was cool but
then Trump happened and it became wacky
true no insufferable no matter what I
said no matter what I did and I'm a very
middle-of-the-road guy I don't know but
I saw you on CNN right yeah I would
always because when Drew had the show at
HLN I would go over and see you all the
time I yeah and what happened you got
fired from that right
latest yeah they just they shitcan the
show because he said something all about
about I don't know if you don't want to
talk about yet he with a Hillary Clinton
he goes she was ill right I think that
how he said to do with it but you know
you CNN's not gonna say that yeah [ __ ]
yeah well what he said and then people
misinterpreted it to what he said was
they they put out a open kind of her
medical protocol her her file type of
medical conditions and then also her
prescriptions yes and he said in my
professional opinion that's a very odd
collection of prescriptions I wonder
what's going on with her it's it's I I
can't understand in what does he think
is going I don't know he said I can't he
just said he take I'm not her she's not
my patient I can't I can't know what's
really going on what I do know is that
this this readout here is weird it's
very weird and that she fainted you know
and then she fainted and shortly after
that and they're like oh dr. drew yeah
and so it's just all CNN they seem to
make a lot of qualms about being very
liberal right and and they're almost a
mouthpiece for the Democratic Party as
is the Fox for the Republican right sure
so so for you Mike though so you thought
you'd do that kind of get out of the
funny late-night Morning Show stuff and
the obviously Trump comes along and then
I do anymore I would come home from work
every day doing three hours of radio
where people would call and yell at me
you know I'd yeah you know what baltics
guns are [ __ ] religion any any type
of topic you would want to do that would
get the phone's ringing would and I and
I like I said I'm a I'm a relative I
think a relatively level head I'm very
moderate and most government socially
liberal but I'm conservative fella too
and in many regards and you you talk
about guns I'd say like yeah you know
III totally understand the desire to own
a gun you know I understand might scare
people but I understand the desire to go
out and buy one boom on Rico how dare
you I do you have children now you wanna
I'm like very strange man why people
can't handle that opposite direction man
it's like I don't understand how people
and it's religious can say men can't
marry another man phone light up you
[ __ ] liberal history it's religious
training people had their weird
religions they anchor into so like so
when when when they're defending guns or
the defending something else what
they're defending actually is their
tribe their father their grandfather
their legacy being in a marriage
these things of that we're very
nationalistic anything that that
threatens what would they would be
consider the American Way or the
Constitution or whatever it might be and
people identify they when you identify
strongly with a tribe or identify strong
emotional
yeah with a narrative with a narrative a
narrative like a story we all we all
have stories that we we kind of align
with right well even like I Rogen always
talks about how people like to join
teams more than anything they even
beyond the ideology they just want to be
a part of that's right and I always
thought like that's why he and guys like
you you both have an affinity for
fighters and comics because you're not
on a team I know that you're not a bunch
of team right exactly like exact you're
aversive to like I'm going to sign with
this team you're like you know I got to
do what's best for comedy like so so you
have to solve a problem yeah okay and it
has nothing to do enduring a team you
can be a Democrat Republican I got to
solve a problem which is I got to go out
there and I got to make people laugh
yeah and the world change is not gonna
change with it
so that means I have to be responsive to
evidence I have to be responsive to
what's in front of me I got a responsive
to kind of like the truth of it and
fighting if you imagine if you're a
fighter and you go
I am only about boxing and I am a purist
when it comes to jiu-jitsu that is how I
fight all my MMA fights I'll do you one
letter B I'll do you one better I think
with comedy and fighting to you can't be
on teams necessarily because you need so
much that it takes a village meaning it
takes you have to be pretty [ __ ] cool
in order to and be humble to work with
this boxing coach and then worked in
some disguise and change and adapt and
then with comedy if I went in what I'm
[ __ ] got it I'm good I'm gonna do my
thing well climbing stores and go know
we're set we have more time to guys than
you we're set here you're not coming in
the door and then when I do getting go
out getting the green room I go [ __ ] all
you I know exactly what I'm doing well
then they're not gonna help very also
you need these people you know Walter
berry you know but very good sue also
like with the social media I used to
have this story I would tell myself and
that story was social media is gross
it's it's it's self-promotion it's it's
not it's a
bass form of and all of it was a story I
was telling myself yeah when when when I
changed that story and I watched like
Brendan and I watched Rogan I watched it
and I was like wait a minute this is
just a great tool to get my message out
there my voice out there yes that's a
great way to hey six grand to a
publicist to [ __ ] we're sitting
somewhere and I told Bryan like dude the
way you and I remember the look on your
face I'm like dude the way I don't like
doing social if I've had a choice I will
not do Instagram and Twitter but you
have to yell or you have to yeah but I
looked at Brownwood
you're your own publicist now you don't
need to hire this guy for six grand you
have this many followers where you can
be here on this date this you can make
your own silly videos at home you do
over you want man
or you can I ask God for six grand he's
gonna get you in this publication maybe
on this TV show this thing goes so much
further that's awesome if you don't do
it like no I I just started like playing
the game where I realize it is it stop
stop saying everyone's kylie jenner and
it's all fake and it's all the
superficial [ __ ]
no it's an incredible tool to reach out
to millions of people there's some
Hilaire stuff on the inspiring stuff you
can get horrible stuff absolutely but
but isn't that just like in the media
like life you chew you pick and choose
I've used Twitter now solely as a new
source meat okay follow for Senator
lights and and I use Instagram for my
boner and I follow I follow fighters and
like Victoria's Secret models and chicks
with fat asses doing squats you know I
don't want to follow that's what I do i
I'm not amazed by this crossfit stuff
from the girls it's for you know i like
muscular gastic so but also you did that
you didn't like doing that you didn't
like kind of the way it made you feel
taking the calls and then what you're
like I am done doing this yeah then what
um nothing really right now honestly
like right now I I did the thing where I
a Bri Marcus really helped me out with
this I don't know him at all
really fact we're gonna have him on the
swirl Patrol podcast and it'll be the
first time I've ever met the guy he's
just so cool he said Jenkins and he did
this this like life kind of coaching
program called go for the win yeah I was
like I'll sign for that what
to lose feel free to win and there was
this adage in there about how Vikings
would burn their ships when they come to
a new land because there was no turning
back
we're either gonna die here or were in a
[ __ ] concur yeah and I just went down
that path I mean right now I kind of
jettison anything else that wasn't
making me happy or wasn't in any way
kind of fulfilling a passion I you know
I was lucky enough to have a wife who
put a lot of money in the bank for many
years on toast and I just said like well
why would I waste my time doing this I'm
gonna I'm gonna be 40 next year so this
year is all about I burned that ship I
burned all my you know I was I was
admittedly resting on my laurels and
radio I wasn't pushing the envelope I
wasn't trying to so where to now what do
you ideal situation
agents friends say we have these three
options Oh ideal situation is my goddamn
animated show finally gets made thought
about yeah I do that like my alter egos
this cholo from you know and with me I
brought do it you didn't do this you're
doing Lovelight or anything like this I
feel it's a great character um eight
series this is this guy yeah it happened
came with me
oh that's a good master not like Oh like
they do this on [ __ ] reality like
base animated shows like king of the
hill but like with Mexicans dogs and
surly and [ __ ] you know what's it about
who are the characters about me you know
Rudy Cisneros like I'm ready to blow up
show the world like my life you know and
like east los like represent for you
know and like the real thing is you know
I didn't choose this life you know I was
born into it ya know like the struggle
keep my head on a swivel and make full
friendly what his motto ed Helmes you
know you know ed hell yeah he hit me up
he's like this make an animated show
about you and I'm like [ __ ] yeah dog
okay so I saw you in the hall in the
[ __ ] hangover with no teeth yeah ed
holmes kind of knows what he's doing
that's a pretty good go so what is your
name my name is Rudy dog nice to meet
I'm a big fan dog thank you brother I
appreciate watch the coma city to the
Goldbergs yeah oh my God look at you in
your short shorts I look at that meat
that karna you got in your pants are
like full and thick I'm kind of jealous
you know you're from LA Rudy I'm born
and raised doc I barely ever left one
time I went to TJ with my uncle but yeah
so um what do you think you want to say
in this animated series is there feel
like family guy but you're Mexican it's
like more like go like go king of the
hill for cause like you know how like
they told a story about East West Texas
talking you know yeah and they really
brought that world to life for the
mainstream yeah I want to do that but
like for for you know East Los Angeles
you know I say let people know it's like
a colorful world no it isn't no I got a
you know beautiful wife with a fat ass
you know she was getting a little too
like fat like poor Panza her [ __ ]
Fupa was getting yeah and she tries like
every child should try like CrossFit in
[ __ ] the Weight Watchers yeah none of
it worked you know so I did do it I had
the do cuz I heard like at night she
would grab her [ __ ] Fupa and she'd be
like crying yeah so I started putting
meth in her food what oh wow like
secretly you put my Reaper dog give me
some stunts and I put it in her food
did it work she lost 125 pounds now 78
pounds she shopped upper arm because I
thought there are bugs in it oh yeah
that's like a downside yeah it's a
downside like yeah but you know
effective you know what I'm saying point
A to point B yeah I understand that
there might be a better way to do it
though whatever is done okay yeah I know
it's not like Oh what do you do for work
whoa right now like I'm assistant
manager Jamba Juice in bukhoma you know
juice right well like a guy hooked up on
like a work-release program
you know they hook me up a show sometime
yeah now I would fifteen years like
that's no
like fat see that's what I rated about
that in the trades dog they call it
facets there's another like aspect of
the shows like you know how to
assimilate back to life after well thank
you very much for being on the fighter
in the kids like my pleasure dog you
know what I'm saying a can I get some
money for a gas yes kick me down a
couple bucks drive all the way back yeah
no problem how about what do you need to
do to get this interracial character
it's a great cake for a while um well I
here's how many Central sat on it for
two years and then they were cool about
it but they they they let it go now Fox
animation has it but like is this moving
without Netflix know if they're moving
super slow then something's missing
yeah I know and I like I do too have ed
Helmes production company and IDI
personally like endorsing all the time
and let me put the pilot together it was
bugging Fred Armisen Danny Trejo write
to him and he's unbelievable I was like
what's missing well Fox has Family Guy
yes Simpsons so they're you know they're
it's it's the it's the Yankee Stadium of
animated shows and it rocks is it's
alright you know I worry yeah I worry
that like I'm gonna go another two years
of like someone sitting on it if they
have the contractual rights to it or
didn't yank it whatever you want I can I
could we can chop it to other places but
they get first- first kind of rights
already yeah I had a really interesting
conversation with this writer Brian
Edward Hill who he's [ __ ] so
brilliant and he said he wrote this
incredible graphic novel called postal
about a kid with Asperger's syndrome in
a town the town is was founded by this
criminal and all the people in the town
are criminals and they live in this town
but there's a code of justice that you
have to live by and he said I said you
make your hundred it's a bill yeah oh
you make your character so [ __ ] um a
lot of your characters they're bad but
there's but as you keep reading it you
realize that they have such a good side
and he said he goes well I've always
been fascinated with mom
Jers who are monsters because they're
running away from something even more
monstrous no and I went [ __ ] man like
the way writers think like they're the
different levels of psychology with your
show though is it because like Simpsons
foxy and ship for a boo yeah with the
with the the guy yeah you know I'm art I
work really so that we could be maybe
cuz the Mexican angle like right now
it's a little touchy for us well I mean
I I was riding on it but I'm by no means
like a really credible writer we hired
the head writers this girl Sierra or
nailless who was she right sort of like
superstore or another we've got guys who
wrote for the office it had brought in
you know so there there's a there's a
concerted effort to a have like a team
of writers that is Hispanic
that makes it usually he's Bank not only
by the way not only Hispanic it's not
just like this this broad umbrella
Mexican from LA like it's a certain
unique kind of perspective that might be
a trap to using like good writers I
agree I mean no I actually I reject that
I worry about that this this there's
this new trend in Hollywood where you
got to have the people writing this
cultural appropriation
it's a bankrupt idea as I'm Lynn Nottage
well but like on blackish if you're if
it's if it's a black demographic you
want cuz you want black absolutely not
yes some of it but you also want all
that I be blogging what is right as I
can write the human experience and and a
huge part of what makes up our show
popular is that there are these human
through lines that we all glean to then
the rest are particular laugh you have
to have up you can have a black
sensibility where there's a black writer
goes you know what actually that
wouldn't really you know whatever but
for the most part take a look at Lynn
Nottage
Lynn Nottage is a black woman with
dreads runs heels drama department wins
a Nobel Prize for an incredible play
called sweat and it's basically about
white men whose factory is shutting down
and they become violent and angry yes
there's a black kid in indigo but for
the most part you walk out of that play
and you go this black woman just made my
heart break for a working class white
dude with opioid problem life and you go
and so so a bit but I'm sorry but art
art and writing especially is full of
people who had nothing
to do with the people they're running
about but they had empathy and really
you know Francis Bacon never tore a
devil you know
Satan's guts out and you know obviously
ya heart is about imagination and I
think I do think that you said that art
is about representing the human
experience and to say that all people's
human experience is the same I mean
woman's experiences yes wildly different
and we can't we truly can't experience
is wildly yes no they'd add value you
need very good with you're gonna write a
show called black cause you're gonna
write it show about you know you
definitely want a or a Mexican
sensibility rights and it'll all have to
be sure sure I mean look like Ed's there
get that's writing and just get the ice
writers think the the thing to me was
like I wanted to make it as funny as
possible and exposed stuff that is
unique and yes culturally very you know
unique to that part of the world and to
those people who are living this really
colorful amazing lifestyle that I don't
think it's exposed often yeah on top of
that though I didn't want to make a
Mexican minstrel act you know like it
that was a concern especially me cuz I
look I'm I got a white last name I
didn't come from necessarily like the
most authentic barrio and so for me I
didn't want people to go and like like
state is like I'm standing on some
pedestal poking fun at anything it's
definitely for my level of love and
appreciation it's like I I don't think
people can understand like you know go
into Dodger Stadium there's a unique
sensibility to like those dudes who like
the the it's different than a Puerto
Rican from New York a Cuban from calls
from Florida it's it's it's a unique
like that yes that Chicano like world so
how long you know way before you want to
get that it's not in your hands that's
what started the the entire conversation
is that like I want to want this more
than anything cuz it means so much to me
but on top of that like I'm tired of
sitting back and thinking like oh this
is out of my control no it's totally in
my control I got Rudy his own Instagram
account
starting you know his own YouTube
channel and things and it's like I'm
just gonna start pushing that content
and if someone's not gonna catch on to
that train then so be it I'm gonna you
know keep that trend going yeah let
Brandon get in there and stick our nose
that's right like hey can you do what
makes him void if we're hey alms that's
here let's hear it
it's here but with that that racist oh
no hon let me try this be I'm worked on
my Mexican boy I'm from Mexico I'm not
gonna take your crap anymore you can't
do mech suit huh I haven't got you
finally ever tried I do I do Asian and
Mexican men think about but that I could
but do you even Asian you have to like
fine Tunes like I mean I get it that's
up but one of the luxuries of coming
from the neighborhood I came from like I
can hear someone talk and be like oh
she's Korean you know that person
Chinese me and chin chin went when I was
on tour in Australia chin went with me
and for whatever reason one that for
whatever reason because of a [ __ ] the
way our world is created Australia where
it's located a lot of Asians go there
for holiday a ton a ton so I went there
I we got off the plane I like to
gentlemen do I'm sorry am i doing shows
in Tokyo what the [ __ ] going on
there's a lot of there's a lot of Asian
population to there's so much there's
literally is weird it was an Asian guy
he's like oh my yeah I know idea yeah my
[ __ ] the Kangaroos weather some Asians
I could I care but then I'd go I'd hear
I'm talking to go chin what were they
speaking to tell me what chin where they
see you and tell me and by the end of
the thing generally speaking I'm like
that's Korean that's Japanese yeah it's
cool man it was cool so there's a big
difference Hey and a huge difference
it's it's like the more that stuff gets
celebrated without like like Brian said
the cultural appropriation where or not
even cultural appropriation that's a bad
way of putting it where you're just
looking to exploit diversity yeah well I
I think there's a big difference between
like what you know what we need to do
Michu is really big let's make a show
about women and you know to make more so
yeah yeah exactly would like something
that does let's do let's do this idea
because it's a good idea and nobody's
nobody's come out there's not an
individual's been inspired by an idea
then they go they get an idea not an
original idea but the suit said then
they hire a bunch of really smart
talented people who've been good at
other things
yeah around that idea and then you get a
disaster like green lantern or whatever
how dare you Green Lantern Seth Rogen
yeah it's crap well I had a famous
director on fun on moonlit house I was
like okay I was I'm lying Hornet
this was might have in the Green Hornet
I'm on the I'm on the things Green
Lantern I'm on Warner Brothers with a
very famous director and I see these
executives on Golf Course Lucas driving
by they're like just a bunch of dudes
and they're just like this
they got tight faces and I'm I don't
know and and and my buddy goes hey guys
and they go hey and I go who are they
and he goes oh that's the that's the
Green Lantern group and they are things
aren't going very well with that they're
going to try to save the movie they were
liked riding to the screen Lantern was
Ryan Reynolds Green Hornet with Seth
Rogen horn again I love green I think it
might have been Green Hornet I don't
know I think this one bond I think you
know here's we never know because it may
a bomb here and it's a nice really knows
in China and Russia that move not really
in this case cuz otherwise they would
have made another one right but that's
that's always the weird thing when you
see like movies like Rhett admitted that
read with Helen Mirren and Bruce Willis
oh yeah I go they needed to make another
one of those would they realize though
internationally it did Bruce Willis
still has you know cash a 43% of run
Tomatoes I tell you what I like that
movie I didn't see it
there's shitty movies I loved and I
stand behind me too like Jack and Jill
with Adam Sandler yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
hey you know what i watch the other day
laugh out I don't care what anyone says
you don't mess with the Zohan it's
[ __ ] hilarious
oh great [ __ ] so
Zohan ridiculous
what's the other movies he's been doing
he did the one with Jennifer Aniston
that where they fake it with like
they're married and they go to Hawaii oh
we could Swartz into insane and that
movie so Wharton's ridiculous in that
movie then here's another movie with
bring up so oh it's just go with it
ridiculous grownups good time these are
all even Africa [ __ ] great
when you kiss six pretty [ __ ] good
that's my boy not Mary that's none of
them though like that the high high end
of the altar is Billy Madison and happy
gilmore how can you beat that though it
was a hey Tom but but that's my boy
phenomenal movie that's a stretch that's
my boy that's my boy with on the lower
end please halt arias in that hey daddy
it buddy probably his biggest moneymaker
ever it was Big Daddy you know that
really yeah Big Daddy was his biggest
blockbuster I'm I'm pretty sure Big
Daddy was his biggest water wedding
singer [ __ ] killer water boy killer
boys oh hey great Jack and Jill great I
know I bet you the grown-ups movies were
bigger those those make huge money oh
dude I now pronounce you chuck and Larry
for come on Longest Yard anger
management I got caught beating off - I
now pronounce you chuck and Larry oh
really which part there's just a be
little undies and I was like thank you
sir and I just I got possessed by this
need to do your job so and my ex-wife
walked in on me how'd that go does she
look like Jessica Biel probably not in
my ex-wife super hot oh yeah yeah would
we know her no no no she's just like she
was a waitress at Katsuya she might know
her cuz you're at eating at kutsu yeah
she still went out there I don't think
so hmm well done Mike
Thank You Little Nicky got a lot of [ __ ]
- I didn't mind a little Nicky pixels
rough I'll give you that piece rough
pixels suck mr. deeds good now that you
know man
you guys have been a real inspiration to
me not only with with Rudy by the way at
culo breaker on on Twitter and Instagram
love it I go find Rudy and but with this
new podcast with dr. Drew you know like
we started this out of he has these
other
wildly popular things with Bob forests
that are talking medicine and they're
talking life you know all these other
kind of interesting things that drew
could dive into and I I hit him up about
the idea of he's legitimately really
into physical fitness and he's super
buff and he is a physician and he
understands mental health you know too
large and too much larger extent than
most people and I said we let's really
do this let's say we're both passionate
about it let's go for it and I thought
to myself like that is I want to follow
the fighter in the kid model of putting
all our effort into it not asking for
help
not needing any massive corporate
sponsor to get behind it's not whatever
it is it's like from a grip from the
ground up you guys did this you got a
you got a following and you built it and
you did all the social media on your own
you did and he pushed it and like the
the merchandising everything like though
you always had your [ __ ] together right
from the start you had a vision of what
it was gonna be even when it was just
getting started you know and like when
you guys are back at Fox and you're
having me as a guest truly know like you
I you uh how long are we doing this five
years yeah five years is that true yeah
is that right yeah
five [ __ ] your garage man and I met
you seven years ago are you kidding me
now we're you know dude what's the AP
with Brennan's hog look like he's got a
piece on he does well I'm not mad at ya
not mad at all some kind of manager is
it's it's I hope he one says I'd love to
see that hog man we sword fight he's got
a piece on these mu dick pics no but we
I mean nothing like this I mean I sent
him the first I was the first guy to
send you a dick pic you and Tony
Jeffries oh that's right you were fresh
out the shower yeah a little no but I
just I think it was he was a half half
math math took a picture of my piece
hanging here and you you know and you
were rightly impressed let's do some
current events just do some curl
I forgot we gotta take a piss I get
pissed you let's take a break before
tournament this mustache way um we got
in the first one is about the FC so this
is from variety
but apparently ESPN and Hawk sport how
do you not call current events chin
music well Jim with chin there's so many
different [ __ ] music chin up chin up
eyes down I'll just be quite over here
alright so ESPN and Fox this is just
according to sources yeah what's up chin
down go on Sheena Sweet Chin Music
I heard so many times music good chin
Chin's chin Chin's don't restaurant as
well alrighty chin dingo toughest guys
in the planet but chin is now chin stuff
right tom it's weird variety pick a
picture of Roy Dell soon doesn't fight
in UFC anymore as their friend I picture
so anyways you know UFC is supposed to
look for a new TV deal
since the Fox ones ending this year
apparently Fox Sports and ESPN are both
bidding to work together for that deal
it doesn't say how much it's gonna be
though is it says Fox is currently
paying 120 million and they would be in
they would end up paying 200 million for
this deal ooh
and then yes piano would be paying so
this is what we thought it's weird it's
like someone caught this so it's so so
what they're doing is based on what
other other sport leagues are doing
where you know the NFL's on Fox and CBS
it's on ESPN diversify yeah it's on all
then no not one channel owns it and then
what they're gonna do is so ESPN let's
say ESPN put off you know they would
have their group of fighters kinda like
boxing has you know so ESPN might have
khabib you know Holly Holm and cyborg
and then Fox would have Tony Ferguson a
man in noon it is it's it's WWE's model
correct you know Raw has a certain
stable and you know the other I don't
not that familiar but and I like the
Sunday night shows have a certain stable
and then the Monday night have their own
fighters and it's backed up and its back
down has their own game yeah it's smart
I mean it makes yeah I mean you know
it's just the you know the ratings have
been down I think they need to do
something what I think the experiment
with Fox has kind of been a bit of you
know what blender it's not on Fox
is you know play it's not all their
fault you know the UFC's had a little
bit of a down slope with their stars and
stuff like that but it's also just
oversaturated like the March is just
over saturate my people all right man we
got it but you and people want to well
look what box in this box on Wednesday
night stuff like that
I know mixed martial arts doesn't have
that same fan base really where the
hardcores I'll watch [ __ ] you put on
Tuesday Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
I'm gonna see it all I am - I'm that
passionate a fan but even I find myself
now and like huh for another fight card
okay especially if it's a pay-per-view
and they do three in a row and it's kind
of a weak card I'm like [ __ ] man
yeah seventy bucks here seventy bucks
there it's like Matthew's was on Joe
Buck's show undeniable and he was saying
the same thing he said there was
something special about when I was
fighting you know you you really got a
chance to to highlight ten guys it was
an event and it was an event it was like
a super vault and that's what they
needed I saw what they leaked a few days
ago I found below the belt where they
talked about selling all of at ESPN and
ESPN would do the UFC would do six
pay-per-views a year which those six
papers are [ __ ] they're super balls
when you're mark you're the [ __ ] out of
it and it's the best of the best and
it's stat yeah the other ones are good
it's like it the you know father you
just barely get good fights when those
pay-per-views it's an event man where
everyone comes the house we're getting
three four million buys if every time
and it's just [ __ ] it's the thing to
do that's what they need to get back to
cuz now it's you're not the NFL
you're not the NBA you're not MLB where
we have to see it it's like well it's
fighting if I don't know a story like if
box on ESPN on Tuesday night if I don't
know the guys you might be world
champion oh he is I flipped on my gonna
go [ __ ] yeah you know also you don't
have the luxury of having team team
followings no you know like I still the
Lakers are [ __ ] trash and I still I'm
like I got a watch you still [ __ ] I
still watch you know 30 Laker games a
year just because I you know I have a
team affinity even if you have a your
favorite fighters you're not gonna
necessarily follow them just because
it's there on a $60 pay-per-view I mean
that's a that's a big leap little sketch
in hopefully it works up oh one quick
thing I don't fits your pet peeve as
well but when you
the Fox shows you know there's like so
many different channels yet to go
through there's FX the FS one at the
Franz likes up for the delay because of
NASCAR and it goes xx square seven I
hate where the [ __ ] that general yeah
yeah
alright so you posted this Brendan
triple G have you guys seen this
commercial no oh it's a great commercial
its own shade at Canelo he's so badass
get ready for this I had to repost this
superhuman power ingredient is a mistake
[Music]
[Music]
and it's called hard work stay food no -
tag no draw
me that great by the neck to meet uh
[ __ ] know who does [ __ ] I'm more madam
for slandering tacos but although I
there there was a NFL lineman who did
prove correct he ate enough Mexican meat
on his vacation that he did test
positive for some there's a few guys
think do you think that Canelo was
eating me or I don't know I don't buy it
at all oh yeah this is just be a face of
course can I was on [ __ ] this just be a
face will get over at the rematch
breaker you know they might throw some
shade at triple G you know a triple G
might throw shade at canal be like well
you're on steroids I'm very cool and
then the rematch to be huge and we all
forget about it sports who gives a [ __ ]
oh really oh guy who's trying to cheat
all crazy and oh it's the highest level
box in the world above course especially
I mean clenbuterol it's not exactly
gonna you know it's not gonna change
it's not like yeah I caught with destiny
as an assassin Gold's Gym it's
clenbuterol it's not a huge deal I never
even found it useful I mean I use going
to be wrong planned it it speeds up your
metabolism right it just makes you sweat
like burn it but if you're trying to cut
weight it's you it's great but you have
still have to die it hard
you still I mean you notice they don't
have to be a really good boxer well no
no but even to cut we're not it's not
like um it's all you taking you cut down
to 154 pounds
why viously I [ __ ] help him like with
like side a mil and other like thyroid
manipulators
that [ __ ] works like that [ __ ] you
literally can be lenient on your diet
you're you're dropping weight oh yeah
clumpy draw that's call side a mil or t3
he doesn't know what to do okay rate
increases thyroid output okay well it
was designed for people who are who are
hypothyroid you know like if you have
some conditionally normal you need
whatever you want
no but you can definitely not be
you know bodybuilding dieting to like
see results you still have to diet oh
yeah I'm always like [ __ ] I might as
well I know but was with Antonello is
she's already dieting and ready to get
down even more so it you can see why you
know you know for sure he's dieting and
you know he's training like crazy so
this display gives a little boost yeah
people think he's dying this way has
knocked out power another cleanse not
gonna make him Jack no he's not we in
splendor all is not winning fights now
if he was [ __ ] with the right
steroids it definitely could be it could
be they lose a few guys give you some
knocked up right I mean there's the the
the people I think if there's more
understanding of certain drugs there
will be like you know for instance like
John Jones the John Jones situation
listen what he got caught with even if
he was in trace amounts which has been
proven to be micro dosing he he's not
had kicking [ __ ] no Daniel Cormier to
death with because of what he's taking
the peds aren't helping him be the
greatest fighter of all right it's
really not yeah it's hinder it's
actually hurting him now he'd be even
better without it now five milligram
even gusting gust Ringo's the stuff he's
taking it doesn't [ __ ] matter he
doesn't need it you think he's he's such
an animal present he does now 500
milligrams a test and some is some
tremble tremble own a couple times a
week it definitely helps Barry Bonds
smash home runs like know if you're not
be pH days if your honor that vitor
belfort
testosterone diet where 14 times higher
than natural man yeah yeah of course can
help you will for off it for him to go
to rise in which you know is give me the
best when he comes off it both of them
with Bane masks on a fight between to
get off it when when you saw it was
there did you see his body but it's
unbelievable I was like he's the best
example of I need for hormone
replacement but but another example of
it doesn't it you know it does help but
you know you do still have skills is
over him yeah he was juiced to the
[ __ ] gills and was no it's just
steroids he gets officer it's still
number one in the world right [ __ ]
pretty [ __ ] good but I do think I do
think it helps you're teachin
I don't stop a lot of like scientific
really and I were talking about this
well I don't know what it is I don't
know the science behind it
there's something about when you're on
test guys can take shots that they can't
when they're awful yeah it has something
to do with like split second reaction
times you get head the difference
probably between this like there isn't
this and that because there aren't gonna
help with that like that sounds like you
give you fast reaction time but it
doesn't nose hormone will mmm maybe but
the thing is with with testosterone
maybe it's strengthens the muscles in
your neck does it make you more
aggressive though so you tend to be more
you're more willing to get step into the
shot as opposed to pull back I don't
think so those guys are aggressive
anyways I think if anything maybe
strengthen cuz it's starting something
we can eat bigger shot that seems the
most reasonable is that yeah face it's
like you can't be like maybe John Cena
has a buff face yes now do to buff face
I wonder if at that like Mark Kahn's
never touch the steroid in his life just
take a shot but then you look at like
MOA
you look at Bigfoot Silva who needed
testosterone just to live right because
you have thyroid in you had giantism and
when he got off of it guys were like and
he'd get knocked out but then he's on it
you know when the greatest heavyweight
fight he's not he's a litter like truly
a [ __ ] up situation like he he should
he should get an exemption he has a
measure D though or half that but look
how good he is with it with it with
testosterone like he's a [ __ ] one of
the best of all time yeah you know he's
top ten he beat you know monster
intimately born with something that
prevents and popping normal maybe
compete maybe you shouldn't be a fighter
because it is unfair because look off of
it
still it's never a champion still got
beaten by guys I just like it I wonder
when the day comes that they make
illegal smart drugs you know people are
gonna start seeing it in their own lines
of work where you're gonna like if you
could take something that's gonna make
you like a limitless pill right and
people you know people throw shade at
athletes for doing this but you know
what I'm saying like adderall amongst
entertainers brighter the point no yeah
adderall is your peds at all for rioters
comics medical school if your medical
school done adderall but I might you
know
down I need to shut the [ __ ] I don't
know have you taken at all
no I joined college everyone's like dude
if you need a bus out this project take
it and I took it and I was like I am
kind in the zone and someone came in
like hey what are you doing and I talked
to them for [ __ ] an hour got no work
done
I'd like where they're from I am wrong
production that day that but peds in
entertainment in comedy in writers room
whatever you do cocaine those uppers
though what about action stars
hey I've laughed so hard that people
like they get so angry at athletes for
using steroids I was like what do you
think every [ __ ] expendable is
pumping into their gills a budget after
Expendables they're like all right yeah
this is all fine but the budget for
stewards is insane right like well yeah
it runs older and not even not even like
the the giant buff you know the rock and
stuff I'm talking about like guys who
Sylvester Stallone just want you know
that that's a different he's he's he's
60 years old and he s is not where the
god bless he's no I'm talking about like
the just the Ryan Reynolds and the
people who have to look sick you have to
have the six-pack on come on Hardy and
warrior yeah are you [ __ ] me you got
to be kidding me he was more juice to
nothing it was as bane but you know what
shred what my actors doing that tiger
likes you ready on a roll like to play
Batman Ben Affleck at the it Jack your
boy who's your boy your boy in the
American sniper
Bradley Cooper you have to bulk up bro
yeah your dude you're lifting all these
dead lists of why not do it oh my God
look at his [ __ ] trap I was on that
movie so oh that's right you were
dominant in that movie too a lot of time
Dominator
I love what's he like it was it stopped
the guys act in the world yeah he's one
of them and why he always have a mask on
every [ __ ] move Tom Hardy's enema
greater bad max Bane he's a he's a
special dude but he walks around 140
when he's not one for though he's a
small dude yeah he's not a big guy also
uh their rarest one 70s I love crack was
he crack handsome oh do you I got one
for you
no he's a rapper you know he kind of
want to be a rapper there's an actual
album out of Tom Hardy rapping no hit it
it's a very talented a hit it he's so
goddamn town he's all had a nose job did
you know that did not know that nothing
wrong taking some off the beak Tom Hardy
crap suck Frias [ __ ] it it all you
[ __ ] didn't know why do you
wanna be a rapper I made it big
she's got classic good looks though
handsome devil said a dear sighs I think
if I had to switch teams he's my number
one choice you're number one it's yacht
[ __ ] Ryan Reynolds I'm going to eat your
progress and Tom Hardy he drew you going
I got Tom Hardy and Ryan Reynolds maybe
you [ __ ] you'd [ __ ] in a day louis
ozzie actor's wife Oh good-looking me
know if you were playing for the other
team
[ __ ] dick I would go I would go Ryan
Reynolds number one Tom Hart is too
small that sucks I'm raucous yeah but
I'll turn that up for me but I bet you
he's getting nasty in the bed Tom
Hardy's getting crazies you know there's
gonna be some wacky [ __ ] going on my bed
are you mad at this track
[Music]
it's better than what half the lil fill
in the blanks that are out now with
tattoos on their face that just mumble
bluesy little he's a talented little
yachty little you know you like rap and
I'm just dropping knowledge on you Fox
you know stealth is a stupid [ __ ]
rapping you can Shia LaBeouf his dude
bring up Shia LaBeouf on when sway in
the morning he's talented oh no what so
swaying the morning has rappers come on
and he allows him to freestyle and then
they judge it right but so it's he has
he said all the big names on Shia
LaBeouf goes on there's all my freestyle
you know sways like dude we I've had
like legit rappers on here they get the
greatest in the world
well okay watch this watch this oh you
didn't do anything so we get ready Shia
LaBeouf yeah but he's my favorite actor
really he's my favorite actor suede look
at all the big shot man I can't hear
[ __ ]
[Music]
Chrissy fits all freestyle it's like
Silver Lake yep get ready get set this
mean this is wildest a childhood dream
I'm that guy though all pride yo do my
thang is stack ride though on that white
oak The Gun Club
I mean one oh that's just dumb club I
don't go there but I get dumb love
legend [ __ ] trash you heard that's all
alleged [ __ ] plagiarists they making
[ __ ] greatest gifts come from painful
[ __ ] truth is I'm a true G only white
kid with big in the Coogee tatted to me
and Tupac too and Missy on my two knees
do please stop asking about my tats like
some groupies
whenever the truce required I'm hired
I'm the go-to guy for fire when the
truce and I needed I beat it
I come from La Migra streets kid I'm
gyro why is he acting up backing up when
the trash is up with his trash I'm gonna
pass the buck tell me why though cuz I'm
testing me for the best to me trying to
ensure this legacy psycho talk [ __ ] I'll
pop up on popping these popping G pop
and see I'll get you high as poppy seeds
copy me you and Heather Knox and me
ragini check me check me evidently kid
is transcending god damn is too
of a date I mean thanks planning you
guys all something he wrote this listens
cursor on the belle of the ball
never thought my rhyme style was
eligible ramzan negligible
unintelligible seals all the difference
really good but he did he did write this
yeah I agree but he this is not this way
better than I could already crazy that
that's very good though little little
factoid Shia LaBeouf's you know his
father was a meth addict clown yeah
and called him honey boy I did not know
and now Shia LaBeouf's playing his
father in the movie of himself I did not
know that he used to his parents would
like like they were like gypsies they
should go sell stuff at like that pence
the Rose Bowls was a very talented mom's
crazy he's crazy he's out there cat we
have the yeah I've heard you know with
the same age separate stories but I'm
like when he was doing that movie was
the movie dude with Tom Hardy where they
were they were the the oh the brothers
the brother yeah I was a good movie from
my family like the phenomenal movie ah
oh my god it was a good movie yeah
anyways when he's doing that movie
thought it'd be better if he had a tooth
missing so he went to 20 different
lawless lawless
he went to 20 different dentists trying
to get this tooth removed and then
wouldn't do it then I can oh we're not
[ __ ] removing a healthy tooth yeah he
just so into the character he you know
he's crazy he's a little bit crazy well
that's what makes oh he's out there cat
yeah for sure I think you show talented
man doesn't get enough credit because it
may be the Disney accolades or what I
know I think because of the off-camera
its off while he looks he's like he
looks a little bit like harm he doesn't
look as tough as somebody like Tom Hardy
I don't I don't think I don't look at
guy I don't like Jared Leto cuz he's
tough Brian I don't think anyone look at
tough I'll play if he plays tough coach
Jared Leto had to fight against his
Jared Leto nice you mean finally now my
people admit they're like [ __ ] he's into
me I still hasn't breaking thread it
hasn't because he's so pretty
dude he's so nobody so so pretty so
happy to god midday - yeah three until
recently he won't last for a long time
like when he was on ocher when he was on
that with a Fight Club is up you were
like this [ __ ] Michael here yeah yeah
he's a beautiful guy that I'd warned
right I wanted to destroy something
beautiful that's right and any and they
as good as he was his beauty kind of
always was something he had to fight
against cuz Pino the movement were
really nice where he became undeniable
to me was American Psycho who
Jared love Jared Leto he was Paul Allen
Jew Dallas buyers club well I mean that
was way too
I had already I mean lord of war and
stuff it happened I were like war he's
[ __ ] amazing I was blown away by how
he acts circles around Nick Cage - oh
they're lime in the same planet in that
movie they can't be a bad actor in the
world under very [ __ ] on thirty Seconds
to Mars
Oh his album it's only the big sound
look how he got really mad at me because
I wouldn't tell him who does my teeth
cuz I go no one I've never I was like I
don't I don't either my teeth I don't
know woody I brush them I don't know
whatever me he's like [ __ ] you dude tell
me it's like who where'd you where'd you
get those veneer that was like such a
good looking guy he's impossibly he's
like he's 48 he's 244 there's guys that
146 there's plenty of guys that come on
in here right you know radio shows or TV
shows that I've been on where I go oh
that's a good-looking guy then there's
dudes and it's only happened twice where
I'm like this is this is uncomfortable
for tears your intimidatingly
good-looking it's yeah he's intimidating
but how talented he is you're like what
the [ __ ] his voice when he sings his
acting and then I think he might be the
only dude who's literally sponsored by
Gucci and just a Jared here if you're
listening to show me just let I love you
my Gucci man you're my spirit animals
you may not get definitely not nope
nothing Jared Leto is though the owner
of Gucci loves Jared Leto and Jared you
know I love the office look at his face
great kill free however just because
Gucci makes it does he have to wear it a
good point like he puts all this [ __ ] on
it doesn't match his a scarf is a Gucci
hat and coat these slacks you see but I
think there's now there's certain people
and Brendan you would know about this
more than anyone there's certain people
that have been established as style
icons and then they just go watch what I
can do and people will go Willow Smith
Pharrell Jacobs Jay
the other day warfare pharrell war muay
thai shorts in the streets he did one
check I'm breathing I'm not kidding I
saw it at first
see for elko so everyone's gonna do that
I'm gonna do like James Smith I'm like
that no you wearing a dress bro that's a
dress they don't count hate on them all
you want but you know who is successful
that that is Kanye Tania can shift an
entire entire dad that had him we're
dead so Connie brought dad hats back he
brought jeans so much jeans their
sweatshirts
but that muy Thai start soccer training
did he's not taking low kicks bro
no break his leg off I want to see Robin
Vanbrugh smile and kick him once so you
know who you know who although white
kids are influenced by Kanye's Yeezy and
stuff like that you know who's the white
Kanye who influenced mainly older like
30 I'd say 30 and older men from fashion
yes the white Kanye hold on hold
there's two of them but there's one
where if you pay attention style be like
people go to his Instagram and see what
he's wearing
and then websites will flag what he's
rabid Cooper M&L got [ __ ] no hold on
okay is he older he's older yeah it was
not super Beckham no although he's
wanted to solid choice that's all choice
your dad's closer
[ __ ] what I forget his name so you'd
have to google him but he's I'll give
you the first one while he goes so
giraffe I loved her I'd loved him on the
show no he's awesome who's Jeff Anson's
boys Oh Justin Theroux just throws like
the white con is you look at his fashion
the YSL boots and the jeans he started
that the white t-shirt handsome guy no
really yeah so those are wife's a little
why sell boots Michael he's little yeah
small very lean oh yeah oh yeah he's
married Jennifer answered breakup single
hey so you see those YSL boots he's
wearing you make fun of me for yeah he's
like that's his [ __ ] man he's the guy so
it's him it's this Justin Theroux guy
and Ryan Gosling so Ryan got Sony wore
the pea coat with a white shirt just a
white v-neck peacocks like sold out
instantly yeah I'm more I if I to choose
like styles prettiest
really respected athletes excuse me
really respected actors I'm going hearty
over gosling any day I hear of course
fashion no as far as just like who I
choose
there was a great guy like real to my
wife my wife said if I live with a man
he has nothing but the most immediately
great guy super eclectic smart funny
unless fashion in the game if you know
fashion I see the problem
am I too old to dress well not the boy
you could do it because you have the
physique yeah you're small like him
don't say I'm small I'm saying like I'm
too big like no but leather colleague oh
I'll go to All Saints and get that put
on it's not about your mouth boy I mean
saucy block look at that
that's another is no dressing like that
I look like Justin you know I didn't you
just said it man you wish you had his
hair so wish I had is how easy fashion
tips from Justin all this justin [ __ ]
justin theroux also 46 just like Leto
I'm saying come on now 344 oh good job
see he's setting the fashion trends for
look at this baby yeah I just don't have
the energy like you have that you have
the body to do it you know like that's
the things like trick the bottle and the
limiting factor to his fashion is that
you got to be shredded to dress like
that you get dressed like that you
should dress like that I shoulder did
you might try even though I have no
business dressed like that
I literally my wardrobes similar to his
but I'm too [ __ ] thick I like hearing
this kind of stuff thanks man but I
don't wear my tattoos on stage but that
look why that's that looks good I knew
that shakes bro you should you should
not be afraid of sharp yeah like I like
the I like the the like Gulf Punk thing
you know where you look like you're all
kind of prepped out but you really
there's an edge to it yeah yeah yeah I'm
a big strong kid what's next a big
strong kid educate the [ __ ] at you guys
dinner yeah beat you bsk you're in bsk
what's next wrong yeah transition rap so
Kendrick Lamar he won a Pulitzer Prize
for his music which doesn't happen I
heard that's crazy not to come
I gotta get involved it is a poet
surprise surprise everyone
yeah Bob there was like a citation so
he'd won in a way but not a real Bob
don't want to know about prize didn't
need for I'm not sure that God what kind
of do you stop doing like collabs with
like Gucci Mane a little Uzi what you in
a [ __ ] pole to be like what yeah no
there's no more of that homeboy fries
man there's no more of that I want to
pull surprise yeah you're doing what my
minimal noise that damn I'm gonna watch
this we're at worse I'm gonna yeah whose
collaborations from here on out ur like
the LA Philharmonic yeah really like
Elton John's playing the piano my
excitement comes out too what a big deal
to win a [ __ ] note history now
imagine this you want talk about
inspiration if you're kidding Compton
they come from nothing
[ __ ] yeah and he's a small do but do you
remember when we're at the spike award
huh there's this little black Brian goes
who's that went that's the best rapper
on earth bang goes him I went I swear
you gots most down to wrap around your
brains that's insane
honey guy say that was true yeah Bob
Dylan talk that how can I receive spring
spring Miles Davis Nina Simone Bob Dylan
or surpassed these people ask race which
is crazy news kids in Compton yeah but I
got a problem with it right surprise
yeah but I got a problem with it cuz if
you're not giving it Miles Davis Nina
Simone Bob Dylan or train well hold on
walk caddy
well the springs to be fair the Pulitzer
is about writing yeah right let the
spoken word more so than anything so
mom's Davis didn't it's not about spoken
where it's about to Britain more it
actually okay so my point being I
believe blood in the fields by one
Marcela's won a Pulitzer so it depends
there's music I think there's different
categories yeah but there are 21 members
on the on the Pulitzer Prize I think
anyway either way [ __ ] that's cool
good for him when did you find her and
the kid gonna win bad you I'd be nice
we're gonna create our own
award called the BS key okay this is
school it big strong kid little
suggestion how about well this is a
scary one
so today a South so this it's been nine
years since an actual demo is your plane
I never [ __ ] who Southwest its engine
exploded and it killed one person
numbered injured seven people actually
killed one person so scary and
apparently that person if that is the
that's the right person that almost got
sucked out and they came back and she
died yeah Oh someone almost got sucked
out so I'm sure it's probably this I
thought they saved the person who got
sucked out so it could be that to them
saving someone gets out of a plane in
the midair as the most gangster [ __ ]
ever think about that but so I guess the
takeaway from this don't sit near the
the jet I'm seriously gonna not do it
anymore if I'm near that thing I might
until you're flying 6rg that much
erosions out the billions of flight yeah
that's a machine that happened he was
this has happened though I know though
you know they do the cow come on get the
carry front the cattle call yeah I hate
that oh here it is a female passenger
was partially sucked out she has sucked
out do you ever I noticed that I did I
do this and it it's weird I shouldn't
and I was thinking about how I know he
going Don Draper probably didn't deal
with it was the opposite where people
walked by him in first class and
probably were like one of these days I'm
gonna be like you now I said if I sit in
first class which I rarely do unless a
television station pay for it when I do
though they seat you first and they walk
everybody by you and I feel just like
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] you feel like a
tool and where I was like man it
shouldn't be that way it should be like
I'm sure it was went in like Mad Men era
where there's the dude with the perfect
suit sitting up in something right and
the guy walks by with this kid he's like
son you you work hard one of these days
this is gonna be you know what I'm
saying whereas now people are like look
at this [ __ ] guy like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it is now look
people the world's full of haters is
what you're saying is Brian gets
don't look at me don't look at me oh
look at me I'm famous you [ __ ] I'm
actually come over to offer it I know I
can't stand its people that wear sweats
on the plane yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] man
when did it become a goddamn pajama
party this ain't your living room I
dress I dress up to go at some with
event I want a suit and tie and I wear a
fedora what's the name of our nation
there's something about being
presentable period there's no respect
for yourself for guts yes I don't go out
the house in sweats man I wear my [ __ ]
ring oh right what else get you
it's made of sock it up bro lizard skin
[ __ ] yeah okay so I watched this show
growing up Harry Anderson oh dude
nightcore nightcore yeah 65 good career
to get out something off set yeah yeah
son found him I guess yeah how do you
die it says natural causes but then I
think yeah well it's a shame man I guys
to have heart attacks you two are gonna
die oh my god a percent I already know
this think it Megan Fox we're in the
bottom that Megan Fox the ultimate milf
it's a yeah no she's like 15 kids well
Ryan my boy Brian that green you know
been married to her for a while but
she's uh I hear he's a cool cat - he's
great she's she's cool I know her a
little bit she's delicious yes get some
issues not to kick her off transform I
met her when she was 19 and dating Brian
my stand-up and I was just like Brian
she's the hottest girl a boner rip a
hole through your jeans the hottest
thing I've ever seen in my life
there no it's true there that first
transformers when she's pulling up the
hood in that belly shirt I thought to
myself well Derrick that might be high
when I metric or everything we ate at
katana me her and Brian Austin Green
armor she was talking about it she was
like I'm going to do that and I was like
[ __ ] that director hits on you then
they had some issues yeah transformers I
don't know damn sure I'd listen if
you're married to her you just
understand that everyone hits on yeah
well you understand what she was telling
hallway we're all trying to [ __ ] your
girl's got her he's got a piece on him
from what I hear
next of course he does did too didn't a
librarians date it's beautiful
these days besides [ __ ] me he's got a
show he was on a show for all you might
be he's not anger management yeah he was
on our that's right son before they was
on the Terminator the movie no the
series with Lena Headey he's always
working Ryan's always working well it's
yet you alright this one how much is all
right so t-mobile owes the FCC the
Federal Communications Commission forty
million for playing fake ringtones on
unconnected calls you know that means
when like say if you're calling someone
where they don't really have great
service yeah the t-mobile would actually
have a fake ring going on looking for
service so most people in here like if
they heard like four rings they want to
just hang up gonna keep going so they've
been doing this since 2007 over hundreds
and millions of different halls t-mobile
I'm a team or I'm not a [ __ ] terrible
man and I can't get on my plan I'm gonna
jump
I pay from you know saying get better
get better do better do you know anyone
else on chemo and I have a hotmail email
speaking of hot males hahahahah sorry
man this is on barstool a group of
baboons so there's a bunch of baboons in
this facility it's a medical facility
testing facility [ __ ] Texas where they
test for disease why do you have a
hard-on baboon suffering [ __ ] you know I
have a hard-on because of the this story
go ahead and continue escape yeah they
escaped so a bunch of them got a
55-gallon barrel they they rolled it to
this fence
they've propped it up jumped on top and
escaped where the hell they got them
steel cell for more testing guys got it
draw your line that's still okay baboons
no bones because baboons
should suffer they deserve to have a
particle but boons are poor guy clothes
that dim walking you can see him here so
the guys are actually trying to catch
him here and he's just on
are those those are Babu those are
baboons God won't they rip those guys
dicks off guys they're afraid that this
is really sad actually yes they're smart
enough to want to escape like you did
already more anymore man yeah it's not
like you know I'm not trying to put
animals on a pecking order but it's not
like a mouse or something mm-hmm like
this big baboon clearly has enough of a
brain where it's like please let me out
of here
No hold up God his homies government yes
and fellas as soon as it lists out
tomorrow serious I'm taking this [ __ ]
roller thing going all the way over here
and we jump over and we're gonna be free
fellas we're gonna be sipping beer to me
great and then these Texas biomedical
research they shoot them up with
different things yeah I need my makeup
and I need to be safe and a couple of
unions have to lose their eyesight then
but I don't think haha yeah boobs though
it's probably not even cosmetic so
they're probably like doing AIDS
research profit stuff in the boom
I like seeing baboon and tomahto Mike
thank you for joining us guys it really
really is such an honor you guys you
bastards like at home the new pocket is
your new show with drew and all that
fall Patrol well when you have me on bro
and whenever you want ice well what the
one time do you do it it varies usually
it's weekends though you know ooh
to try to make room for drew I know I
know
Sunday afternoon hold you have to yeah
dad let's see if you have December first
I've never available or Sunday
afternoons that's that tough once what
listen we're doing we're doing Monday
night for Monday night yeah Monday and
Sunday
worse even worse it's not me I got to
work around [ __ ] dr. Drew schedule he
has 11 jobs who am I gonna hang out with
you and dr. Drew I'm a cadet all right
let's do it slow patrol let's do it now
control come see me this weekend in
Boston I got in the next weekend is
Denver and then I got to Kaluza casino
may 5th let's go tickets tief at
kake.com this weekend I'm in Calgary but
yourself out nope we jut we added a
third shot
Oh Raja three shows on Saturday we added
4 p.m. show to meet God Yuk Yuk's and
Calgary I want to grow and I can speak
jokes Calgary this Saturday we added a
show the others are sold out Yuk Yuk's
Calgary Friday Saturday doing show
available Saturday 4 p.m. get you some
and then May 4th and 5th mall America in
Minnesota
I am there May 4th or 5th and then West
Nyack over those dates Beach West Nyack
here there
I feel May 17-18 you're right West Nyack
17th through the 19th t fat cake on four
tickets
Houston June get them this is the firely
kid we're out